like I remember the first time I watched
Sarah for the end and I remember it was
like it was like a show with a
post-apocalyptic show right about like
how vampires have taken over the world
yeah and then for like four episodes in
there's just a [ __ ] high school and
I'm like well why is there a high school
that if there's one show that doesn't
need a high school dynamic [ __ ] this
show I'm like guilty cuz like I'm like
the only guy I think you read is read
like all of that manga so far lizards
don't know I'm the complete opposite
guilty I'd never consumed anything about
it which is so weird because for the
longest time I don't know if you guys
got these messages so many people were
asking me to make a video so it's got a
really big female fault yeah yeah yeah I
don't think there's been a single an
issue that's made a video on it cuz we
use they're all because they're all
dudes few females we have the first
episode of zeref the end was like I
wanted like the best first episodes yeah
I remember for a while the way it had is
such a good first episode in the Rye not
even the lines really good world ending
Wars and then at Yale except high school
gets really good again when they leave
high school
it doesn't quickly abandon that and I'd
like to think that's the artist be of
the author being like yeah it got really
good and I'd say well like about
two-thirds through the manga because I
hasn't finished yet but about two-thirds
for the manga where it is right now it
gets amazing yeah and then it goes like
not so good yeah cuz did the manga
deviate from the anime because I
remember watching all of the anime and
it's it was one of those shows where I
had a good time watching it if I
remember correctly the manga was really
really similar to the show right and
they build on a lot of the things that I
thought were really interesting in the
show amazingly in the in the manga as it
goes on yeah but then it became really
weird and world ending what kind of like
trigger II Ryan it's yeah I don't really
like the main main like the final
villain that they have as well it's just
a fine it's fine it's right is one of
those shows where I'm like I had a good
time watchin yeah I'm not gonna ever you
watch yeah I'm probably not gonna
remember my would you recommend people
to read it or watch it because I haven't
either if you I would say watch it and
if you like what you watched and
continue onwards okay I'm gonna probably
enjoy it I think yeah okay up to a
certain point and then you'll start to
be like confused and it's good there
it's good I like how they did a lot of
things and like the most Trump sentence
ever I like how they did things I like
the things I did I totally get it
because I actually agree view like oh
yeah it was good
IIIi had a good time it's it's like it's
like the most six out of ten ever it's
like it's it's so very decent and I have
minimal complaints yeah there's not much
to it and you're just kind of like I'm
happy I'm happy with what happened I
don't want anymore it was before I had
like five Issa guy to watch every season
but and this is took the space of that
when this came after right after the
hyper-v season one of attack yeah yeah I
remember every was hype is fog for this
and yeah and then it was pretty [ __ ]
hide yeah just kind of just it just
didn't take off and I don't know why
that's right it is well because the
anime had like an amazing like fight
scene in like yeah like a like an
orchestrated like white light they were
hunting down these vampires really cool
episode and for some reason that wasn't
enough it's one of those shows that
weirdly like I hear some people talk
about a walkabout but I don't really see
anything about you know because I think
people who read it are really really
into it yeah yeah it's good I think the
problem with it is that I just kind of
liked its own identity when it first
aired cuz I remember when it first met I
think like I made a joke that I was like
oh it's like a taco and blue axis with
gay vampires also very much is like an
amalgamation of a lot of different
aspects yeah yeah and the main character
is kind of annoying yeah yes that's true
as well that's never a good thing
it's annoying because it's like I like
all of this we're getting a lot of this
one thing cuz I'm just kind of wish
would just be a little less like potent
you know yeah yeah there's a lot of
shows like that there well I've read the
manga after it and no one really spoke
about it and I was like I don't really
know I like a certain black clover black
clay I didn't read a man hey man black
clover is dude
I'm repping black he's gonna he's gotta
go off for 40 minutes about it
my monkey brains like taking over now